hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar as part of our webinar
miniseries today we will have part two
of dissecting the tumor microenvironment
tools for isolation and flow analysis
the speakers title today is isolation of
tumor infiltrating leukocytes kills and
optimized workflows for faster and
improved analysis I am Judy O'Rourke
elaborate and I'll be moderating this
session today's educational web seminar
is presented by lab roots the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning it's brought to you by Milton E
biotech Milton E biotech is a global
provider of products and services that
advanced biomedical research and
cellular therapy the company's
innovative tools support research at
every level from basic research to
translational research to clinical
application this integrated portfolio
enables scientists and clinicians to
obtain analyze and utilize the cell
Milton e biotechs technologies covered
techniques
sample preparation cell isolation cell
sorting flow cytometry cell culture
molecular analysis and preclinical
imaging there more than 25 years of
expertise spans research areas including
immunology stem cell biology
neuroscience and cancer in clinical
research areas like key mythology graph
engineering and a phoresis the company
also offers comprehensive scientific
support consultation and expert training
to learn more about Milton e biotech
visit wwl-tv biotech com let's get
started you can pose questions to the
speaker during the presentation while
they're fresh in your mind did you so
simply type them into the drop down box
located on the far left of your screen
labeled ask a question and click on the
send button questions will be answered
after the presentation to enlarge the
slide window click on the arrows at the
top right hand corner of the
presentation window if you experience
technical problems seeing or hearing the
presentation just click on the support
tab found at the top right of the
present
window or report your problem by typing
it into the answer a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this is an educational webinar and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process of obtaining your credits I now
present today's speaker phase our
Evaristo PhD dr. Evaristo received his
PhD at the University of Paris Descartes
in France in 2009 after seven years as a
research scientist in the US and Germany
he joined Milton E biotech in 2016 as a
team coordinator of the Rd tumor
immunology group he focuses on immuno
oncology preclinical research target
discovery and oncology related product
development dr. Evaristo will now begin
his presentation thank you Judy I'd like
to offer muon to this webinar I will
start by giving a short introduction
followed by a few slides highlighting
some of the practical challenges that I
faced over the years as a tumor
immunology researcher and are surely
common to many of you and our colleagues
finally I will tell you how we generated
solutions for these challenges and were
able to significantly improve our till
research workflow
immunotherapy has proven clinical
efficacy and tremendous potential in
multiple cancers but even patients who
experience clinical benefit from these
new agents often achieve only partial
responses such that additional work is
necessary to improve immune or
therapeutic strategy namely to fully
understand of the dynamic interactions
between the tumor microenvironment and
the immune system and the effects of the
different therapies in till biology
tinge innate mouths tumor models
represent the gold standard to study
immune responses to tumors and analyze
the effects of immunotherapy as they
possess a fully competent in you know
immune repertoire however the phenotypic
and functional analysis of tools is
technically challenging and
labor-intensive as this figure
illustrates solid tumors are complex
tissues containing multiple cell types
the amount in composition of cumin for
creating leukocytes is highly variable
which complicates the analysis of
individual populations at this time we
would like to prompt you a question that
you're going to be seeing on your screen
please answer the question
you
indeed to frequencies can be very low
for example one of the most widely used
sin genic mouth tumor models is set up
by inoculation of about half a million
be 16 f10 melanoma cells subcutaneously
in black six mice these cells will
establish a solid tumor that can be
analyzed typically between one and three
weeks after tumor inoculation these
tumors are typically between 200 and
1000 milligrams and contain around 10 to
the 8 cells per gram
the necrotic areas of these tumors are
quite significant such that the
percentage of viable cells can be as low
as 20% of those less than 1% our cd8 or
cd4 positive T cells in these dot plots
I'm showing an actual example of flow
cytometry analysis of a dissociated b16
f10 tumor after acquiring over 200,000
cells and getting on live cells
lymphocytes based on four scatter side
scatter and single cells we ended up
with only 266 CDH T cells if we would
like to further phenotype these cells
and identify the subpopulations of
infiltrating CDH T cells we need many
more cells in that can be very time
consuming using this same example we
calculated that in order to acquire 5000
CDH T cells for proper phenotypic
characterization of the subpopulations
we would need to acquire over 4 million
cells per sample if we acquire the
samples at a rate of 2,000 events per
seconds this which takes 36 minutes per
sample and if the experiment contains 20
different samples including different
experimental conditions controls and
replicas we would need over 12 hours
just for acquisition of the labeled
cells
and even before getting to those cells
the mouse has to be sacrificed and the
tumor resected the tumor then has to be
manually dissociated followed by
enzymatic digestion the resulting
suspension that needs to be filtered and
often a density gradient centrifugation
is applied to exclude some debris stem
cell and tumor cell the number of cells
in the resulting suspension is counted
the cells are labeled with fluorescent
antibodies and dyes in our then finally
ready for the longer position times in
front of the photometer I estimated the
approximate amount of time required for
each of these steps in my own experience
however the gross majority of
experiments are done using multiple
minds if for example we have an
experiment with twenty mice these times
had up and we can end up with a workflow
that requires up to 20 hours to complete
which is far from ideal
therefore it is fundamental to use
effective innovative tools to streamline
the workflow and generate high-quality
data to this end we have developed
solutions for all the steps of
mainstream Cancer Research and
established workflows combining them to
decrease the time required and increase
the quality of the data generated this
of course starts with collecting and
storing the tumor tissue sometimes when
working with large cohort or the
material has to be collected from
multiple origins or at different time
points or for any other reason the
tissue cannot be directly processed
during this storage period necrosis and
apoptosis must be avoided and the
functional properties or activation
status of cells must remain unchanged to
prevent causing bias in downstream
analysis the max tissue storage solution
has been developed to allow an optimized
storage of fresh organ
and tissue samples it has been tested
and validated on a variety of human and
mouse tissues including tumors lung
parts brain spleen Ken kidney and
skeletal muscle this graph shows the
number of cells per gram of tissue
recovered after storage in different
solutions for 48 hours as for degrees or
room temperature as compared to the
fresh tissue on the column on the right
in this graph shows the viability of the
cells in the same conditions as you can
see tissues storage in max tissue
storage solution at 4 degrees maintain
the original cellular yield and
viability even after 48 hours with no
induction of apoptosis or increased in
the grossest and no cell activation or
influence on marker expression
we are ready to process the tumors we
automated the tissue dissociation using
the gentle max and the tumor
dissociation kids from out using these
tools automated Association of multiple
samples can be done in parallel it
combines both mechanical and enzymatic
treatment for efficient dissociation
this means the disruption of
extracellular matrix and salad asian
components
without destroying the integrity of the
cell membrane while simultaneously
preserving the cell surface epitopes
indeed optimal tissue dissociation can
be essential for the recovery of the
cells of interest to illustrate this
point we resected a b16 at 10 tumor
divided it into two different samples
and associated them in the gentle max
either in the absence or presence of
tumor dissociation kit enzymes in the
figure we can see - the expression of P
110 3 and lagg-3 on teh T cells
recovered after the tumor was associated
in the absence in the top versus the
presence in the bottom of the tumor
dissociation kids enzymes pd-1 lag 3 and
Tim 3 identify a population of exhausted
tumor reactive T cells that as can be
seen in the upper row are not always
released without optimised enzymatic
digestion these data show that enzymatic
digestion is essential for the recovery
of important tool population
furthermore we do in health control of
the quality of the enzymes used and the
tumor dissociation kit was optimized for
epitope reservation we tested over 200
epitopes the vast majority of which was
not affected by our enzyme composition
I'm not expecting you to be able to read
this but this list of tested epitopes
can be accessed on our website once we
have a self suspension we improved the
isolation of tills
by developing micro bead reagents for
the enrichment of cd8 t d for Pam T
cells or cd45 positive tilt directly
from dissociated tumor tissue using
these reagents based on max technology
the dissociated tumour tissue is
directly labeled with a specific
microbeads optimized for use in solid
tumor the micro beads labeled cells are
then magnetically isolated resulting in
very efficient enrichment of the cells
of interest
this process can be done manually using
individual columns it can be automated
using the auto max Pro separator for
high throughput needs the multi-max cell
24 separator plus allows the semi
automated isolation of up to 24 samples
simultaneously hi put throughput
self-isolation can also be fully
automated using the multi max Peaks
which incorporates a liquid handling
system
at this point we would like to ask you
another question that will be showing up
on your screen
you
we reset it v16 tumors associated them
using the gentle max with the tumor
dissociation kits and compared the
frequency of cd4 cd8 or total T cells
among live cells either in the bulk
population or after specific isolation
these graphs show the frequency of the
indicated cells in the bulk sample on
the top row or after isolation on the
bottom on the last for example the
frequency of cd4 T cells on b16 F 10 was
0.18 percent in the both tumor in 92.4%
after isolation showing that magnetic
isolation can increase the purity of the
cells of interest up to 500 fold the
middle plots shown the initial frequency
of 0.96 % CH T cells in both be 16 F 10
chamber being increased to over 80
percent purity
and on the right panty sells in be 16
over tumors increased from 6% to over
80% after isolation
we calculated the amount of time
required if we wanted to analyze 5,000
cells of interest from the samples
showed on the previous slide with or
without magnetic isolation without
enrichment to analyze 5000 cd4 T cells
from a 0.18 percent frequency you need
to acquire almost 8 million cells if you
use a flow rate of 2,000 events per
second
that would mean over 1 hour effects time
per sample if you have 20 samples you
could be spending over 22 hours
acquiring all samples or more
realistically you would reduce the
number of cells required for sample and
compromise the quality of the data from
your long experiment however by
magnetically and enriching the T cells
we can acquire the same number of cells
of interest in just about 20 minutes
these 20 minutes already include
automated mixing and rinsing between
samples on the next one
we magnetically isolated t-cells from
multiple Mouse tumor models such as B
1641 and CT 26 and compare the frequency
of t-cells in the bulk sample versus
after till isolation these graphs show
the frequency of cd4 on the Left TDH in
the middle and total t-cells on the
right in cell suspensions from the
different tumors indicated on the x-axis
before isolation in dart for after
magnetic enrichment in white bars as
these graphs show we consistently
achieved over 80% purities among live
cells in all the models we tested we
also measure its T cell recovery after T
isolation these graphs show the number
of viable cd4 CH or total T cells
recovered for 10 million cells from
suspensions of the different tumors
specified typically T cell isolation
resulted in cell yields between 50 and
90 percent
besides the time benefits magnetic
isolation greatly improved the quality
of faucet cytometry analysis of tumor
infiltrating t-cells we isolated be 16
over tumors and phenotypes to the cd8
t-cells by flow cytometry either before
or after CDH till isolation these plots
show the analysis of bulk tumor samples
after death cell exclusion on the top
plot going from the left to the right we
gated on lymphocytes then single cells
then CH positive and finally on antigens
experience c-44 positive t-cells on
those cells as you can see on the bottom
row we analyzed the expression of
several markers of interest to tip to
characterize tumor infiltrating T cells
such as p1 lag 310 3c d 39 th CR 3 and C
D 103 due to the low number of CDH T
cells analyzed even though more than
150,000 essential required it is
difficult to draw high confidence
conclusions from these data however
acquisition of just 50,000 events from
CDH to isolated samples resulted in a
much more robust phenotyping of the cd8
t-cell population as you can appreciate
from these dot plots
see cell isolation was particularly
important to assess the cell entrancing
functional properties of chill tumor
infiltrating T cells are often
dysfunctional which correlates with
tumor growth the mechanisms leading to T
cell dysfunction can be either cell
intrinsic like energy or exhaustion or
extrinsic like suppression and
starvation it's often important to be
able to distinguish between these two
types of mechanisms the common
functional assay used for T cell
characterization consists in measuring
the capacity of cells to produce
cytokines such as interferon gamma this
is done by simulating cells in vitro in
the presence of a secretion blocker for
four hours followed by intracellular
staining of interferon gamma and
analysis by flow cytometry however
several immunomodulatory molecules are
expressed in the tumor microenvironment
which can affect the read out from the
functional assays to illustrate this we
resect it and dissociated 41 tumors
either isolated the T cells or not we
stimulated the T cells or not with place
bound anti cd3 antibody for four hours
at 37 degrees in the presence of breath
of in a and then measured the frequency
of cells that produced interferon gamma
in the different conditions
this graph shows the frequency of C DHT
cells that produce interferon gamma when
cultures in medium along on the Left
were after wrist emulation on the right
when the cells are cultured in bulk in
dark were after T cell isolation in
light bars indeed a higher percentage of
th T cells produce interfering gamma in
response to CD 3 stimulation in the T
cell isolated sample as compared to the
bulk sample indicating that factors
present in the bulk sample suppress CDH
T cell function this was confirmed when
we reconstituted the original tumor
composition by culturing the isolated
cells with the negative fraction and no
longer observed any functional
difference when compared to cells that
did not undergo the isolation process
finally the isolated tools were labeled
with reiha finiti antibodies and
analyzed on the max ones analyzer a
fully automated photometer
at this point we would like to ask you
another question
you
riah finiti antibodies are genetically
engineered to enhance reproducibility
and eliminate bias all antibodies have
one universal igg1 isotype which reduces
the complexity of the experimental
planning in a mutated FC region that
eliminates FC receptor binding mediated
background we dissociated mammary
carcinoma tumors and label them with a
hybridoma derived anti CDH antibody on
the x-axis counter stains with an anti
cd3 staining on the y-axis either
without FC receptor blocking reagent on
the left or with FC are blocking on the
right as you can see using the iGrow
doma derived antibody resulted in the
false identification of cd8 alpha
positive cells within the cd3 negative
cell population this experimental
artifact was most likely caused by her
specific binding of hybridoma derived
antibodies to FC gamma receptors on the
other cells as it was significantly
reduced when using an FC our FC receptor
blocking reagent in contrast labeling
with reiha Finity antibodies wasn't
changed in the presence or absence of FC
receptor blocking therefore providing a
more exact analysis of different cell
populations using these optimized
workflows we were able to reduce the
time required to do the experiment I
described in the beginning of this
presentation
from between 8 and 20 hours down to
around 2 hours
this was done by collecting the tumors
on the previous day and storing them in
tissue storage solution performing the
automated dissociation of multiple
samples in parallel using the gentle max
and tumor dissociation kit automated
cell counting with the max once in
magnetic isolation of the cells of
interest in all samples in parallel
using the multi Magnus
separate
furthermore isolation of t-cells allowed
us to interrogate the sentencing
functional properties without the
influence of the highly immunomodulatory
cells present in the tumor
microenvironment
finally cells were labeled with reiha
finiti antibodies which reduce
background and increase the quality of
the data and analyzed using a max point
analyzer this instrument decreased hands
on time as well as total acquisition
time by facilitating fast and fully
automated sample processing including
sample mixing and absolute cell counting
in conclusion we showed you that
optimized tumor association with
enzymatic digestion is essential for
recovery of important tilt populations
that Ria's inity antibodies facilitates
- analysis by eliminating bright
background in that magnetic isolation of
t-cells from mouse tumors can
dramatically decrease the time of
analysis while increasing the quality of
the data generated furthermore it can
prevent bias in the functional
characterization of fields we believe
that using these solutions will
facilitate tumor immunology research and
contribute to the development of better
cancer immunotherapies I would like to
finish by acknowledging my team and all
my colleagues at Milton a biotech that
made it possible to put together these
workflows as well as our collaborators
at the University of göttingen in at the
University of Bonn for providing
material and testing our work flows off
sites
thank you thank you doctor Evaristo for
your presentation a quick reminder for
our audience on how to submit questions
simply type them into the drop down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window labeled ask a
question and click on the send button
dr. Evaristo will answer as many
questions as time permits the first
question is I work with my own
collagenase dissociation cocktail is
this compatible with your tell
microbeads okay the issue with any only
brew dissociation cocktail of enzymes
that contain for example collagenase is
that accrued collagenase will have
additional enzymatic side activities and
this can contain for example Tripucka
activities and the issue that the the
side activity will differ from lot to
lots which makes it impossible for you
to have consistent results
we have we have seen ourselves that when
we are using when we were using
collagenous to dissociate the tumors
before we have the tumor dissociation
kids sometimes we would lose the
expression of molecules like for example
c4 on ourselves and sometimes we
wouldn't to control this variance in our
results into a voyage having to test
each new lot of collagenous we decided
to standardize our dissociation so we
carefully chose three purified enzymes
giving us the advantage of controlling
their activity this allows us to even
predict before we start the experiment
which epitopes will be sensitive to our
dissociation enzymes as a shoujo during
the presentation we have a PDF list
available in our websites where we
tested over 200 common epitopes and show
their sensitivity only about 5% show
some degree of sensitivity when using
trypsin on the other hand over 50% of
these epitopes would be affected so even
in the case that you find your epitope
to be sensitive to our kids all you have
to do is to preserve all epitope is to
reduce enzyme are in the kid by 80%
so only using a 20% of the suggested
concentration you will decrease your
recovery a little bit but you will
preserve your epitopes so to answer your
question if you can be 100% sure that
your dissociation cocktail never Cleaves
off the required epitopes for subsequent
cell separation and analysis and yes
it's compatible but especially when you
are looking to analyze to leftwards in
require a large variety of markers I
would be careful
well thank you your next question is I
also work with human material do you
have similar solutions for that
currently we offer our optimized tool
microbeads for cd45 cd4 CH and a
combination of cd4 and cd8 for mouse
just in March we launched our CD 45 to
microbeads for human tissue and we are
currently working on the tool on the T
cell specific cd4 and cd8 isolations is
also for for human but I cannot give you
a date for their release yet generally
we are aiming at a release at the end of
the the year but you can definitely use
the CD 45 to microbeads for human thank
you
how do your normal microbeads differ
from the gel microbeads our normal
microbeads were developed for a
different purpose if you look at cd4
microbeads for example one of their key
applications would be to get the cd4
t-cells from spleens where they are
fairly abundant this is very different
when working with tumors t-cells are
rare populations in a tumor as I showed
you during the presentation and so in
the tumor itself is a tissue that is
very different from from the healthy
tissue we optimize the tilt microbeads
specifically for the tumor tissue they
perform better in the tumor and we
strongly recommend you to use them for
the tumor tissue thank you looks like we
have time for one more question and it
is for me
viability and purity are the most
important factors what kind of viability
and purities do you usually experience
after tissue dissociation and then till
isolation
we usually achieve purities between 80%
and 95% among live cells the viability
of isolated cells is increased as
compared with the non isolated samples
but it depends a lot on the type and
size of the tumor that you're working
with and also the initial frequency of
dead cells but we so if your downstream
applications require high viability I
strongly recommend using our deaths or
removal kit prior to the two isolation
when we did this we achieved over 90%
viability so I guess this was the last
question I would like to thank you all
for attending this webinar and your
interesting question and hope you enjoy
the rest of the day until next time I
would like to once again thank dr.
reberty Stowe for his presentation I'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions questions we did not have time
for today will be addressed by the
speaker via the contact information you
provided at the time of registration we
would like to thank our sponsor Milton E
biotech for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on-demand through November 2018
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye